para observar un orangután es necesario
ir hasta las islas indonesias de borneo
de sumatra el delfín rosado con su
singular hocico nada en las aguas del
río Amazonas este gorila del que se dice
estímulo y Pacífico se esconde en el
parque nacional de longú en gabón su
punto en común todos están bajo amenazas
de desaparecer en su último reporte la
organización World War font llega una
conclusión alarmante en medio siglo la
población de animales salvajes
vertebrados ha caído en 69%. la
explicación la destrucción de sus
hábitats 80% de la deforestación mundial
se debe a la forma en que producimos y
consumimos los alimentos otra causa de
la desaparición la casa que no cumple
las reglas del desarrollo sustentable
pero para esta ong es el calentamiento
global el que amenaza más la
biodiversidad si no limitamos el
recalentamiento a 1,5 grados Celsius el
cambio climático se convertirá
seguramente en la principal causa de
pérdida de biodiversidad Durante las
próximas décadas el ejemplo más
alarmante son de agua cálida la mitad de
los arrecifes se han extinguido en 50
años pero los hábitats de Agua Dulce
tampoco se salvan 76% de los peces
migratorios han desaparecido
70% del agua dulce del planeta se usa
para producir alimentos y cuando quitas
tanta agua de estos sistemas eso lo seca
y se pierden esas poblaciones de este
modo una de las especies de las que más
rápido declive observamos es por ejemplo
el estudio europeo frases
en total América Latina es la región más
afectada con 94% de declive de la vida
Silvestre después de 50 años seguida de
África Asia y Europa www F hace un
llamado a los participantes en la décimo
quinta convención sobre la diversidad
biológica que tendrá lugar en Montreal
en diciembre pide un acuerdo mundial
ambiental para salvar las especies
salvajes